you can see me this weekend going to my
favorite place florida you know you're
my people you know you're my people i'm
going to dania beach florida the improv
comedy club this weekend may 12-14 then
i'm gonna be the following weekend in
omaha nebraska at the funny bone the
20th through the 21st st louis funny
bone in june 3rd and 4th houston texas
june 10th and 12th i'm going to be doing
a local show at flappers we're going to
sell that out on june 18th
west niacc new york june 24th through
25th austin texas august 4th through 6th
springfield missouri august 19th through
20th pittsburgh
tempe
caluso california kansas city missouri
irvine a lot more just go to
annieletterman.com shows
and you guys next week i will be in
minneapolis and chicago i can't wait to
come back to the midwest these tickets
will sell out please get them at
esteronice.com and i'm also coming to
denver and austin is rescheduled and dc
is rescheduled i'll see you guys there
[Music]
oh is this our show are we doing the
show we're starting with mouth guards
today i went to tmj doctor
and he gave me a mouth guard i have a
day mouth guard and a night mouth guard
welcome to the dark side
i actually don't i don't have a dark
side i don't have a mouth guard i just
have the energy of someone that would
you i mean scream mouth guard yes thank
you you spittle like you have a mouth
guard in but my mouth guard made my
grinding worse but i'm assuming it's not
that tight yeah it's like but
i don't have that yet they they did the
thing where they mold your teeth and
everything i wish that i would have gone
that route instead i made what i thought
was a questionable decision during the
time
and now i'm thinking it was a poor
decision overall
was remember we talked about getting the
photo
tmj
what a [ __ ] mistake for me you got it
for me yes what i never told you you
kind of look like you got it what your
face is a little i didn't get it
recently
a while back did it help but do we need
it no it helped with the pain because it
didn't allow me to clench
but it changed the shape of my face so
badly that i lost the i like my face
being plump and fat
and round like that's what i yeah i look
like a halo cheek
skeleton no i don't have it anymore it's
been like a year
though but it made me like exactly that
it made me kind of hollowed out and i
maybe that's the appearance some girls
like i don't like it for myself and it
compromised my smile like i love how big
my mouth is i don't want to we all
demise
carlos please look into my eyes i love
how big my best narrative of you and
carlos makes me so uncomfortable wait
tell me why because i have my theories
of carlos
i think it's funny but
i i just can't see it
let's prove it wrong carlos there is
like actually there is a new russian tv
show where you have to guess which one
of the guys on the show is gay they
stole from us
no it's all just you lined up though
one in a wig one without a wig there's a
lot of controversy around it cause
they're calling it homophobic but
if they're right on who's gay they get
twenty eight thousand dollars oh i'd be
rich two million rubles it's not a lot
in america but yeah i i would lose this
show i i've only like solely dated gay
guys i think but you can also like who
knows if they're gay you can seem gay
and not be good yeah it's definitely a
homophobic concept for sure that said i
want to be a contestant on it
if you're gay and you pull off being
straight do you win money
you should i it is considered yeah ultra
homophobic and the producer behind it
was also in the government oh okay oh
really that's bad yeah so it's like
state-run anti-gay tv
isn't russia anti-gay like yeah they're
not very good to the guys
and the show is called i'm not gay
where male contestants just compete to
prove how not gay they are that is so
sad that's what i have to do every week
here
i'm always on this show
i don't think i'm good at it you like
the attention
you love it hey let me tell you
something carlos i'm a proponent for
your anti-gayness okay thank you yeah i
feel like i serve the other side i want
you to you definitely serve it um
i want you to be yourself
okay well i am myself and you still call
me gay okay i just need to be more
yourself okay
um
but okay wait carlos i wanted to tell
you something so i it was my my friend
club soda kenny who is like this uh
he's the security guard for jim norton
and i think he works with bilber and
madonna and amy schumer stuff he's
really cool he's this big amazing man
club soda kenny but it was his birthday
the other day and i had a picture of him
deep throating a banana
from when i used to open for jim norton
and i wanted to post it for his birthday
but i knew it was in the beginning of my
instagram so i scrolled back and i
scrolled back and i went through my
entire instagram and it's so good you
guys please go through my i mean
hilarious since day one
but you know what i noticed
one of the i in the beginning i you know
i didn't have that many likes i didn't
have that many followers guess who was
one of my likes
who carlos
he's been my friend for a long time so
anyone that wants to hate
we've had we have a dynamic okay there
you go i feel like you're not even just
reminding the audience you're reminding
yourself like i feel like you've
forgotten i was like oh we've been
friends for a while yeah well things got
weird since i stole the brody shirt
they've already sweatshirt oh yeah can
you imagine that
now i'll like you know i can probably
clean that i can figure that out that's
what shirt out for you annie are we um
post egg extraction
they scooped me out i feel scooped do
you really do you ever feel yes i feel
terrible do you ever feel like have you
ever imagined what it's like to be the
ice cream container after this
you just think of the scoop right yeah
oh i've been scooped you really feel i
feel scooped no way i feel scooped what
is it
it do it's not it feels like it feels
like cramps
ab workout and something else some scoop
a scoop yeah a scooping yeah but you're
done now right like now you're on the
way up yeah it's all done the eggs are
being well i did decide to we decided to
make embryos which is like if roe versus
wade gets turned over and they make me
make all them like if they're like you
have to have all of them
i'm gonna have the best reality wait
we'll carry some six for esther six for
me yeah yeah no we're dividing those
eggs up yeah you got i feel like you got
a lot of it by 24 eggs then
14 were like mature
then they fertilize 12 so then they're
going to see how many from that they're
going to send i feel like i'm scared of
your eggs like they're going to bully me
so you're a little horny
you love being blue by me don't play
this game
but like the eggs is like a whole new
thing are you horny for annie's eggs i'm
down i'm hungry for her eggs
oh my gosh should we cook the extra ones
up yeah just eggs comes frozen
[Laughter]
but it is like i'm like don't worry
about abortion you should be attacking
me this is crazy what did i just do
oh you're like feeling like you're drunk
with scientific powers it's very weird
you've been harvested i've been it feels
strange it does feel weird i feel empty
and very full at the same time that's so
cool i went down to acupuncture today
and i felt like when she put the needles
in like air was just gonna shoot out
i'm i'm honestly so jealous that you got
that done like
that now you know you have them they're
out
even though i've always said that i
don't ever i've i've given you
controversial advice i feel like our
whole friendship i've always said that
you don't need to freeze your eggs
because your eggs are always going to be
fine
and i feel validated because you got so
many eggs i will say that
you you can't really take the advice
from a younger person that has not
frozen their eggs from that but
the reason that i okay and i did like
those
i did like when people said that to me
like i loved them people were like you
shouldn't have to freeze your eggs i'm
like oh great okay you're right i'm
going to take the insurance policy but
the thing is that i
would then once i started thinking about
it you know when you get like a camera
you see cameras everywhere yeah like
once i started being like you know what
i'm not gonna freeze my eggs every 42
year old to 47 year old [ __ ] that can't
get pregnant just approached me and told
me to freeze my eggs i swear to god
everywhere i'd go someone go just do it
i wish i did it really i swear but i
think it's just it depends on the person
it's just like who is it and then the
whole reason i decided to do this was
because
after i got vaccinated i
went and got like a
a blood test and
they checked my fsh score and
it was just way lower than it had been
right before i got the vaccine which i
later found out was because they tested
me at the wrong time
yeah but i freaked out and just that
freakout made me realize like i do want
to have kids and i do want to like have
the option
i'm glad i did it it was
dr wong was amazing um but
it was definitely a lot i was like
stabbing myself with hormones every day
how many days did you have to um do the
stabbings i think it was 10 days i don't
even know i'll blend it in yeah it
wasn't like i guess in the long run it
wasn't that long and it's not like that
bad like i'm here i'm fine and it's for
a better cause and i'm glad that i was
finally able to have enough money to do
it
give me your belly
it's so full sana
is like i think it's like the tail of a
frog so it's some type of positive curse
i put on you do mine
do my vagina it hurts
and also is the tail of a frog
does it go inside
the tail and enters it
i so did you guys see the news about how
roe v wade is like supposedly going to
be overturned
um
it's funny because i got like a few dms
from people that are like why haven't
you spoken up about roe v wade i'm like
turn your dms off [ __ ] i have to turn
these dm's off what are these people
think my stance is on i'm like a i don't
know i just you're like i'm a robe
you're fish row i had an abortion last
year that one was not
by choice but i know but would you have
not been able to that's why i'm
wondering it's so sketchy that they want
to overturn it like it doesn't make any
sense i think in california you would
have been fine yes oh that's true yeah
and in illinois yeah
yeah um
i get the same messages as you and i'm
like have i not spent the last decade
talking about my own abortions i don't
know what else you want me to say that's
why they're overturning it [ __ ] it's
your fault be quiet about this stop
shouting your abortions [ __ ] let's
pretend we don't get them
well i also get i don't
i personally don't love like the social
media influx of like donate to this
donate to this and that's me that's my
trigger because i growing up like i did
not grow up with money and so whenever i
saw like celebrities posting about where
to donate i was always like [ __ ] you
you're rich like you donate i see some
holes in the story why where were these
celebrities posting when you were little
no like literally like they would put
videos out oh right trust me maybe i
wasn't little but a hundred percent you
know
you're like i just mean how i am now it
was last week
what do you mean i was just like are you
trying to play it off like you're 17
right now
dave accuses me of that all the time
because we were talking about that show
studio 60 on the sunset strip because i
made a tick talk about it and
um i was like i dave was like i watched
that show i'm like i remember when it
came out i was really little i was like
i was a kid and then we looked it up and
i was fully like 18. is that the one
with matthew perry
yeah okay
oh matthew perry matthew perry
but yeah like
side note obviously we're pro-abortion
yeah we're pro-choice
go get an abortion
but i'm very you know careful about
i mean i learned my lesson like
in the past i've always just been like
around trisha paytas even the first time
we had her on tiger belly i openly
talked about my abortion like fully
assuming that she would like be on board
and i didn't take into consideration
that she was having a difficult time at
that time with trying to get pregnant
and like conceive so like i was like oh
[ __ ] story line from party of five by
the way oh is it i love you
jennifer love hewitt was adopted yeah
and nev nev campbell got an abortion and
she was like but i would have been in an
abortion and she like ran and cried oh
god that is a very now did you try to
get an abortion and then the christians
came and tore your shirt off at the
clinic can i tell you a story about this
shirt i actually got this shirt um
on a trade i traded i wanted this shirt
so badly from somebody i traded her
another white dwight beater without
holes but over the years it's really
just come apart and i don't know if uh
it does look yeah it's not gonna hang on
much longer so this might be the last
time i wear it maybe esther will tear it
off or carlos you know i have a family
member i'm not going to say what but a
relative outside of my
unit are they uh
non-binary no
but i just don't want them to like
[ __ ] sue me but i have a family
member who
carly sue over here
hurley don't sue me his dad wanted to
have him aborted
and i and but didn't and i feel like
this family member of mine let's just
say he's my uncle like i feel like he
has not let go of this fact and it's
like he's carried this with him his
whole life that his dad wanted him
abortion who told him that this is
information you don't need you're like
gather around children let me tell you a
bedtime story about how your father
wanted you to be you're supposed to
reframe it as oh you were the surprise
not uh you know we wanted you gone in
one of those bins those plasma bins yeah
because i feel like that would get
inside someone's head like you were the
unwanted i never went there i was like
who cares because even our friend benji
was
his mom wanted to wow does that explain
so much
there's a darkness in him and he knows
he's not supposed to be here
see so you guys are saying if you knew
that you someone wanted to abort you it
would affect you if the way it was
framed like if i had a great childhood
and it was not something if my parents
said that to me once like we actually
thought about terminating the pregnancy
because this was our situation and they
said it to me once i would be like oh i
understand that because i'm an adult and
i understand how things can be hard but
if every day they were like oh you were
the mistake every [ __ ] day of my life
that's not even what we're talking about
like because i i just have always been
like grow up and get over it like i feel
like this has like made this person
crazy their whole life
am i wrong though like would it i the
as a daughter of someone who is adopted
yeah abandonment issues that come with
being adopted i would assume you maybe
get some of the abandonment issues of
someone saying i literally didn't want
you here
yeah was his dad like i made a mistake
i'm so glad you're here i don't know
yeah we don't know the insides of all of
it so it's hard to say like don't say
inside oh sorry her insides have been
scooped
i'm sorry it's my fault
you got gutted i got and then i went to
the acupuncturist today yeah and she
goes and she's this like really
beautiful like older russian lady and i
like her a lot and she's
she's like oh you're gonna be such a
good mother she goes what are you
thinking of like inseminating and i was
like oh in like a couple years and she
goes
that long and i'm like i just spent all
this money to do all this thing so i
didn't have this pressure on me [ __ ]
yeah
i'm going to have a talk with her but i
do want to ask you about that though now
that you know that there is an embryo
like does it make you kind of curious to
see like wow i could get that done today
if i wanted to
it's not that but i did feel i started
to feel like maternal over my eggs like
i wanted to sit on them and hatch them
like i want to sit on them and hatch
them i see you're making me wish it was
actually eggs that sounds so fun
you're so weird
you're so cute
how like you could bounce on them eggs
yeah like you can like see them and hold
them while they're growing you know what
here's what i'll say
esther you have a point did you keep
your abortion by the way i feel like
you're stroking your abortion
right
no but i think like
when i was pregnant for three months for
no reason i
do you want to explain your type of what
it was
oh my god i well okay
i i talk about it in my stand-up and i
feel like i'll save it for that but
it was
traumatizing as [ __ ] because when i got
after they do the abortion
they tell you um
they test it and then they tell you like
what
what was wrong and i had this like super
rare kind of miscarriage where they were
based it was so [ __ ] traumatizing
they're like so now that you know you
know
it didn't work out also you can't try
again for six months to a year and you
might it might develop into cancer they
were literally like you might need chemo
because it was it was a called a partial
molar pregnancy which annie is obsessed
with
anyone i know to have a pregnancy called
molar
but like well you grew something kind of
cool yeah but
of the biggest hype one of the bigger
hypochondriacs i know to be like it
could turn into cancer but you handled
it well i it's like almost when that
things are that traumatic you just
there's nothing else but survived yeah
yeah i actually think who was i talking
to someone i was talking to was like i
think esther had an ego death from weed
like usually people do like strong
hallucinogens to like are you sure it
wasn't the nyquil or the day i will say
i do think there's truth to like going
through something traumatic and
you just come out of it a different
person and i feel like that's what the
miscarriage really did for me and
like
i look at it like i learned that i can
get pregnant if i want to yeah like i
because before that i didn't know if i
was going to be able to because for some
reason my mom always told me that i was
going to have a hard time which is my
mom too very weird thing for moms to do
what i wonder where that comes from i
wonder if they're just trying to scare
us into doing it that's what it must be
you're speechless my mom said well my
mom said to me
it was actually funny she was just like
well i just thought you were like such a
[ __ ] like you would have been pregnant
for me i think it's because my dad's mom
struggled to get pregnant and that's why
it's kind of rare for his generation
that he's a only child yeah because they
struggled but like for me i just look at
it like i learned that it's easy to get
pregnant if i want to and i'll do it
again when i want to but i'm not
necessarily
ready again you learned that you could
miscarry on
[Laughter]
keep calming keep calm and miscarry and
also how common miscarriages are yeah
did you feel like was there any sort of
like relief of like the fear of
motherhood when it happened
no actually i think later
but you guys i cannot stress to you
enough how traumatic it was to be told
that moment where they're like so
it's not it's not there anymore like
i just i remember like the mask i was
wearing i had to throw it away because i
was so full of snot and tears
and
yeah it just was really like i'm
comfortable talking about it now like
almost a year later because i'm through
it
a drug addict now just kidding
uh
but you know i've worked through it and
i'm still working through it but i'm not
going to deny like especially to people
who've experienced that like that
initial trauma
because you'd gotten yourself like
into the yeah you think you're you've
been you like you said yeah you're
feeling maternal over your freaking eggs
there you go yeah
yeah so you get it
and you've had several abortions and so
let's move to the other area of female
reproductive we are we were such a good
mix of different
options um but that's exactly what this
whole roe versus wade thing is like it's
not
an abortion isn't one thing it's 50
different you know situations and
circumstances and joys and sadness and
everything like it is such a complex
thing that you can't just
say oh well abortions are bad for who
for what yeah if i didn't get an
abortion when i had my miscarriage which
is a which some people don't need it
like the tissue will just go away but if
i hadn't it would have literally turned
into cancer right in my [ __ ] uterus i
would have had cancer if i didn't get it
sucked out
guys
yeah what the hell
and also it's just like there's no it's
like it's so judgmental to like you
don't know what anyone's reason what
what if the supreme court is like so we
did take that into consideration that
esther would have had cancer and we
approved
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
online therapy
life can be overwhelming and many people
are burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped attachment
fatigue and more i've had all of those
we're all like acting them out right now
by the way master's like half asleep
most of us just associate burnout with
work but that's not always the case you
can be burned out for more than just
your work we were just in a global
pandemic we were just all in a very
weird traumatizing thing that everyone
went through there's a war going on
there's crazy things there's
a supreme court threatening to overturn
stuff a lot is happening right now yeah
and better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself and
talking with someone can really help you
figure out what is causing all the
stresses in your life better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to and i had therapy two days ago and
guess what i did not want to see anyone
well i called annie right before therapy
and i i just it was just a really bad
day for me and i didn't want to see
anyone on video not in person and i had
the best session over the phone and
that's an option for you was it because
i annoyed you so much on facetime that
you were like i'm done with like seeing
people
sounds like we all had a rough week last
week i'll just leave it at that
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours this podcast
is sponsored by better help and it's all
love and trash tuesday listeners get 10
off their first month at
betterhealth.com
trash tuesday that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-elp.com
trash tuesday let's talk about liquid
death
because it's my favorite drink and you
would be
i think you might be dead without it
because you did need something like to
make you feel cool i really drink water
thank you this green is my favorite
color i i don't care
it is also so freaking cool looking this
green in this tall boy can this is a new
severed limestone severed is so good too
you know i like fake blood i like
severed things the new flavors are
delicious there's mango chainsaw
severed lime and buried alive i know
dave is obsessed with the berry i like
the lime
um
and all of the flavors have three grams
of agave nectar in them so they're kind
of like a different take on sparkling
water with flavor like they have a
little bit of sweetener but not a lot
it's they're really really good yeah and
i like the way agave sweetens things
it's very different from just plain old
sugar
it's uh we don't do sugar okay come at
us
well agave is sugar but it is we don't
we don't do cane sugar right
we don't do white sugar [ __ ] okay and
why is it called liquid death because
they're bringing death to plastic and 10
of the profits from every canceled are
donated to help kill plastic pollution
love that and what i like about these
guys is you know i i don't drink often
so sometimes i don't know what to do
with my hands at a party at a social
do they call them gatherings
at a social event and i like having this
cool freaking can to just
i agree i know if you don't have the can
what else are you gonna do with your
hands no i always dangerous
when you said that my mouth did this
her hands might just slip onto a dick
um
i love sparkling water i feel the same
way and i always want sparkling water
with me and i always want my liquid
destiny when i'm out you guys can get
free shipping on all water and merch at
liquid death dot com slash trash that's
liquid death dot com slash trash or find
liquid death at 7-eleven target
albertson safeway or amazon but we say
go to liquid death.com trash so they
know that
our fans [ __ ] love it and us
that is one of our reasons here
i think we should submit you then we
should submit your story it is a little
frustrating because i remember like i am
a little embarrassed of how rah-rah went
during the women's movement but i do
feel more about because it was i was
triggered it wasn't like it was not a
grounded thing and it's okay to be
triggered but i was just like the most
like raped and raw i'd ever been and it
was just like
it just felt i just felt so like i was
just very unhinged which is okay to be
in
and whatever but
i just i honestly the main thing i'm
very smart was the [ __ ] the head the
hat that's what i gathered yeah it's
really the hat yeah it's just they
tricked us they tricked us they tricked
us whoever made that it was not that's
what i feel i think that if you had just
gone and walked without
you would have just been fine you're so
traumatized by that it's just so it was
are there pictures
i could find a picture well then let's
burn them so you don't feel traumatized
oh my god maybe we won't post it you
don't get to see my [ __ ] hat picture
carlos was all psyched he's like oh i
get to put a picture in
um
but
i remember
my
guy friends being like oh abortion's not
going to be
overturned like i was like how do you
know right how do you know
i will admit though that i would have
been on their side and been like of
course abortion won't be overturned are
you crazy and you just think that it's
uh we're so far past that that there's
no way that we can regress as a society
in that way because you know like you've
i've used planned parenthood you know
like
that's always been at my disposal and
i've always felt very safe in knowing
that like as a woman living in
california but like
but i guess you know it can't get you
comfortable did i ever tell you guys
that so when i first moved to la and i
was so broke and i
i i would do all my um gyno
gynecological what is it gynecological
whatever i mean that's so amazing i
but i would go to planned parenthood
frequently
and
uh they would always send you the nurse
was hot
give me the duck bill they would always
send you home with like a bag of condoms
and i was in a committed relationship at
the time and so i didn't use condoms
whatever did he use some of the other
girls
[Laughter]
i really hope he did
i'm not sure
um
i'm like how far do i want to go into
that but
but so one day i finally went to go get
my car washed and i got a detail because
i had learned what detailing was at age
22 and
when i came to pick up my car all these
guys were standing outside it laughing
and staring at me and i was like what is
going on and they get to my car and it's
all cleaned out but there's like
three huge bags of condoms
and i'm like these guys think i'm a
[ __ ] hoe
well they're unused yeah and also
yeah annie yeah i'm allergic
sex sucks and my vagina smells like
rubber um
wow okay wait
have you had planned parenthood
experiences i've been going to planned
parenthood since i was 16 years old that
was my spot in santa fe yeah and they
gave you that government card that gave
you you know like basically free i
always got my birth control from there i
always got my pap smears from there my
checkups my s anytime i needed to be
tested i used planned parenthood like i
got all my did you guys ever do the depo
shot i never got the job
it took my period away for one year and
then i got it for six months straight
i had my mirror
honestly i was like
i think that's like you can use that in
court as a reason why you come undone
like anyone like i always thought this
like come undone that's funny like i
remember when christina aguilera like
everyone was really like just [ __ ]
on her for putting on this weight and
for not like being the the older she was
so skinny oh my god and then she comes
out and says like she had been on the
depot shot and i'm like look i think
that
a lot of things can be solved you know
there's a twinkie defense the guy who
killed harvey milk um he was like oh he
couldn't find milk for his twinkies so
he killed him well his defense in court
was i ate shitty for i ate just straight
sugars for however long and
um and
it became crazy from it they call it you
could pull it up it's called
defense
um
but i don't know if he got off but that
was a defense that he used but i think
that the double shot is like gotten off
to twinkies i was going to say
for me to not know about that as a
missed opportunity
so um so the twinkie defense is a is
that it's not a recognized legal defense
let's just but they use that right but i
think that the depot shot is like i
think is passable in court is saying
look my fit caused
psychosis
how did you feel on the depo shot i was
like woo i got my period this is awesome
i was like this is the [ __ ] i love the
shot and then i got off and i was
so upset
six months
just no underwear left no couch is left
unbled on even on the lowest dose of
birth control i
almost got into a car accident for like
trying to get to a gas station to get
ice cream was that when you were doing
this was that when you're doing whiskey
ginger no
when i didn't know i was that was bad
friends when i drove down the stairs
if you saw the stairs you
all would have done the same thing you'd
you'd get it i know it's like we saw the
stairs
yeah we saw i saw the stairs yesterday
it doesn't look like a driveway at all
my most sexist moments are when i see a
car abandoned half on and half off of a
curb
a woman or bobby
you have two options there sexist and
racist either way
um my planned parenthood memory though
is
i had uh
this woman go she was like giving me a
cervical exam and she goes oh do you
want this skin tag removed and i went
skin tag
and she goes yeah you have like a skin
tag it was like a like a
i guess a hemorrhoid it turned into like
a mole in my [ __ ]
and i go what
i was like so embarrassed i was like i
have a skin tag in my and she was like
yeah why don't you come in next week to
get it removed i go okay i come and
expect that oh she doesn't work here
anymore yeah and then i was like oh okay
so who's gonna like we don't do that
here and i was like wait you can't just
like tell me i have a skin tag on my
[ __ ] and then leaving
the country and then she's gone she
escaped she's like i don't want to touch
this
but eventually i got it removed but it
was a whole surgery
did you get wait but it wasn't a
hemorrhoidectomy
is that what they call it because
they're
tired no i don't think it was it was
just they removed it and then they sewed
it up and i had but i had to wear i
remember i went in and the guy it was a
valet at the hospital
and he was hitting on me in the way and
i was wearing leggings i didn't know
this was going to be a thing i thought i
was going to be like get out of here
girl
so i go i valid my car and the guy's
like damn he's like look checking me out
i go in
i get the surgery they literally put him
in a surgical like it's a whole like
operating room and then they're like all
right you have to wear this ice pack out
so i had this giant diaper yeah i looked
like i had a dick like on both sides of
my body and i went out and the guy was
like oh oh damn and you could hear him
get so upset when he saw my
protruding [ __ ] oh no because i know
those things are really really painful
like they say hemorrhoidectomies are as
painful as like i think a gunshot to
your calf i don't know how they're able
to compare the two
that person's had a rough life
also why does a gunshot to the calf
sound good gsw baby you want one yeah
they're like baby gun i'll do it my
calves are sore all the time
she's a walk walk walker i try to talk
to esther the other day she goes i can't
talk i'm walking i was like you're the
only person in the world
that's when you talk is when you're on a
walk she's like it's hard i'm like oh my
god it really is i can do one thing i
cannot believe it i'm like this bad and
i also always have people hitting me up
to join me on my walks and i'm like no
like
i can't i can't do it anymore
like you're a business now
yeah like my well no my walks are like
mental health
like they're free you listen to music or
do you just think i do it all but i just
have to be like i'll listen to a podcast
i'll listen to music i'll just silence a
podcast deal someday trash tuesday
sadly that's true they're for you and
for you only i want to ask you guys some
this question though do you guys ever
feel like your best ideas like you come
to life and all of a sudden you have 50
ideas when you're in the shower yeah
why is that is it the hot water like
fully dilating
our [ __ ] blood vessels i think maybe
you're like kind of like shutting
yourself off to the outside world or
something i don't know i have a trash
tank idea then what is it but can i just
interject yeah you i will have to be
honest that i have not taken a shower in
like three years
so i don't relate why don't you try and
see if your brain comes alive maybe i
will there's something about
i don't know what it is it's like
what does it hurt you you're like oh i
just i take baths and i even have like a
little shower head in my bathtub oh i
bet you do so i just sit underneath i
bet you do
i bet you no i've never done that really
yeah that's the only reason to have a
detachable shower and i've always had
when i've never that does not just i
always think i'm gonna peek in my elder
years you are really ready for it
like you are ready for like a geriatric
bathroom now
oh yeah you are just setting yourself up
to just be bae spongebob it's true it's
true okay i want to hear your trash tank
idea i think okay so when i'm in the
shower and i have all these swirling
ideas in my head i never have a notepad
i never have the phone ready like i want
to make 50 phone calls and i just want
to spew ideas all so i want to create a
bathroom board a shower board basically
where when you have when you're having
those ideas in the shower it's a
waterproof area to write down all the
ideas i
does it exist yeah there's something
called i think it's called aqua notes
that i got for dave aqua notes yeah it's
like a notepad and a special pencil that
like can get wet and you put it up in
the shower oh [ __ ] they beat us they
beat me but i actually like the idea of
a board
and i even think that it should just be
like a big decal they do have it already
yeah
i but honestly it sucked it doesn't it
hurt i didn't like it doesn't it hurt to
realize yes no more great ideas down the
drain that's what that says doesn't that
hurt
no one time i had a joke and i i looked
it up online and you could google image
it was a meme
uh that happens
that happened
yeah all weather edc pocket memo
notebook waterproof of course they would
have a watch no i think your idea is
better i like a board it's dead esther
it's down the drain okay esther's trying
so hard to keep trash tank alive
by the way whitney cummings posts a
picture of herself she goes roast me
esther goes i can't you're flawless
literally that's what i felt i lit and
you know what else my strategy was all
those people will roast her and then
she'll be down on her on herself and
she'll have nowhere to go but me
people were tagging me like get her
annie i go i can't give it to her when
she wants also also that picture that
she posted of herself quite possibly the
tannis she's ever looked so beautiful
the most gorgeous she's ever loved hair
right so you're not wrong yeah that
photograph she's flawless
i was just speaking my heart i'm like
look at her i love her does love a pink
and red together
that's so terrible to do i would never
tell people to roast me really
no
roast me
give me compliments hey guys i'm gonna
post this i only want on my birthday i
always say that in lieu of presents
compliment me but also send me presents
to the comedy story one year i had like
a really small group of people over for
my birthday and were they short or just
not
[Laughter]
and like i made us all sit in a circle
and everyone had to go and take a turn
telling them telling their favorite
memory of me it was my favorite birthday
yeah
yes how old were you so how did you
announce it esther hey guys i really
just want to sit in a circle and i want
you guys to yeah i was like okay let's
all sit in a circle and like we did it
and it was so much fun i don't think did
everyone else have fun or was it just
you probably just me
was dave there so mad yes
stewing in a circle like come to think
of it it was just me dave and my mom and
your mom's like i like that it's hard
for you to get pregnant
[Laughter]
that's my thing i do want to shout out
my mom for never applying that pressure
on me ever in any direction at all she's
just like if you want him great if you
don't i totally understand yeah like
she's very like in fact um
she hasn't said this to me but to my
sister she's like don't have kids you
you're very happy you seem very you know
um you know like good in your skin and
you like your life she's like i get it
don't have kids does your mom have more
than just you two
um i have a sister who is adopted who's
older
so it's the three of us um but she comes
from a family of ten
and in that family of ten or siblings of
ten ten siblings
in that family there's a lot of murder
and chaos so i kind of understand why
she maybe feels like
murderers hanging up on a cross on the
holy week
you're you have an older sister who's
adopted yes yeah but she was adopted
when she was 12 years old and how old
were you when she was 12. i was uh five
or six uh you adopted her you're my my
family my father did so she has my last
that's juliana's mom
oh okay yeah
um look at carlos i got horny
it wasn't horny i was just
saying i also know
he went
yeah but i do want to shout her out for
never putting that
um the typical pressure of being like
hey have kids now i want to shout her
out for that that's fine i'm not going
to do that but you're oh no you're not
only a child and they already have kids
no my mom has grandkids my dad doesn't
but my dad is like your mom my dad's
like i don't care don't don't do it but
now he wants you to have kids right no
he's he's
he's very chill about it yeah he doesn't
there's no pressure
he just wants me to focus on working
and not let anything get in the way and
when when i had the miscarriage he was
like i'm just glad you're okay oh that
is sweet yeah yeah yeah yeah cause i
would have sucked if everyone was like
we're so like you're like i don't want
to deal with your sadness too yeah which
i feel like ultimately that's
unavoidable yeah you are a hard patient
though i will say oh what what you are
such a hard patient esther you just got
uh this you got your um dnc right you
got this procedure done
do not do anything strenuous don't
travel don't walk around airports this
is your time to be in a wheelchair of
all the times
i was so determined to not let having to
get that procedure affect my plans with
my best friend for her birthday
and i just i [ __ ] up you're so
obsessed with christina i know
does she feel this way about you no
she makes it very clear
not at all
but
yeah i had a really hard time after that
yeah i think it took like four people
four of us to be like you are not going
anywhere and then you still did yeah it
was you and dave were so
scary to me at that time you guys were
mad at me and i was like
off in a different place right
yeah but
yeah
that was i'm sure i've talked about this
before but like that night where i over
did it and then had the worst pains of
my life like
i was on the bathroom floor in the
basement and i was like it was the first
time in my life where i was like i'm
okay to die
i was like i can die here was your ego
death
this was it
i was like i'm in so much pain and i'm
on the floor of the basement bathroom i
was like this is the i can go out here
and that's okay
i was really comfortable with that
but um then i took a hydrocodone and
i'm gonna be honest with you can be
really hard to see the light at the end
of the tunnel when you have high
interest debt and sometimes it can be
even harder to ask for help and that's
where upstart comes in you guys saying
goodbye to high interest credit card
debt is one of the first steps towards
financial independence but the interest
month after month can feel like you're
in a never-ending hamster wheel i know
that pain i it is just one of the most
stressful things and i don't want to
have to think about this is why upstart
i think everyone should have yes
and my financial advisor does tell me to
do it yes esther upstart powered
personal loans can help you pay down
high interest debt all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms and upstart has helped over 1.8
million customers on their path to
financial freedom whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses upstart can help you get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date it's like a one-stop shop
for all of your things to get paid off
basically with it you don't yeah you
don't have to be like making sure that
you made all of your payments on
everything and by the way
it's hard enough for me to just
keep my credit cards
in my purse in general
i threw one in the trash and started
getting charged at a golf place so
okay
what i really like too is that you can
check your rate in minutes for loans
between 1000 to 50 000 without impacting
your credit score
don't wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com
tuesday that's upstart.com tuesday to
check your rate today and don't forget
to use our url to let them know we sent
you loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
tuesday
[Music]
and that's
now you didn't call it a dnc right
it is what it's called yeah yeah the dnc
is also curious
the democratic nationals oh yeah yeah
okay i was just i was like sam tripoli
was in my head that's what you call an
abortion an abortion pretty much okay so
an abortion is that painful and horrific
and people are like people are just
getting it for fun yeah just enjoying it
and even when i talk about my abortions
i talk about it in a very like
dismissive oh it was easy i felt
relieved but that's just not the case
like i was my last abortion i was
emotionally miserable i was physically
miserable you're bleeding for like a
whole [ __ ] month like it's you know
it's a very hard decision i know i i
feel this pressure to talk about it like
hey guys it's nothing because that's
what i want to promote yeah but it is
very hard on a woman and those choices
are so
taxing it's really
hard it's sad and depressing either it's
like so because i just was so angry that
i had to deal with it and that it was
getting in my way and you just feel like
helpless yeah but yeah you guys that's a
good point it [ __ ] sucks and dude
abortion
that abortion pill
hurt like the cramps that i got from
that pill i was doubled over and on top
of that when i went for a recheck
because when you take the abortion pill
they're like hey you have to check
whether or not you know that the
pregnancy was terminated and it wasn't
that happened to my friendship doubled
she had a double try to get it then i
had to get the dnc
and so
you know it's not something maybe i've
you know i've made the mistake of being
very like ahaha i've terminated
pregnancies so i've killed babies but
they're like also that's how i cope
that's obviously that's clearly how all
three of us cope yeah i try to make it
like light and funny but no there was
nothing light and funny about it like it
hurt my heart deeply i actually was
going through an old finsta account i
had and um
which has always been had two followers
dave and carlos for the last 10 years
and i saw an old post from when i was
really depressed this was unrelated to
the miscarriage this was january of 2020
i think we all remember how bad i was
and i saw on this this dramatic post i
wrote about how sad i was i wrote um
if you see me crying please just laugh
at me that helps me like i was telling
dave and carlos like i want to be
laughed at because laughter is like the
oh it's so comforting to me yeah i don't
know i just wanted to like highlight
that if other people out there
are like us did you you liked my tweet
at you today that was so funny
i saw her oh my god so what did you
tweet at her i have about my hot swedish
neighbor waved at me yeah
and you wrote let's have her on the
podcast which i'm so glad you knew it
was a woman what was it though yeah oh
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] so hot and then annie
wrote i wrote is it is your neighbor a
red fish
just imagine you just
sting them in your mouth
oh my god no
i know how i know how to do esther humor
yeah
it is banana break time
[Music]
i
think that
um when we get older and perhaps
let's suppose dave has left you todd has
left you bobby has left me
we could just
resort to being in an old lady
throughput together a million yeah we
could just be eating each other's
[ __ ] we can do that with our
boyfriends mmm that's a good point
you know all i want is like a sleepover
i want to live with friends so bad and
in fact i would
don't even get don't do this with me
because i will 100 commit right now to
literally just renting a house for a
month and living in it like we all live
together we have a month and it's so
much fun like i know we should do annie
and you know
i don't know careful what you wish for
because i think this is what annie are
gonna and i are gonna do because we're
trying to like just bring you out of
your um gay shell
we're gonna force you to eat us out
every [ __ ] night every night we're
gonna be like you don't have a choice i
don't care if you're necessarily giving
her in the morning because we know she
washes more than me this is so weird but
like okay
but you don't get anything in return you
just have to eat us out
every freaking day and you're going to
be like my neck muscles and i'm like i
haven't come yet she's going to be so
annoying it and you have to make us come
to it's too complicated
with our [ __ ]
we're gonna have to skull [ __ ] with
our badges
that is very interesting to me that
concept do you ever like when you're
mastering do you think about really just
like spreading it and licking it
or is it more like playing with boobs
and grabbing ass
i do want to know the question i know
there's not a guy we know there's not a
guy there that's a good question what do
you think of esther
you guys i'll tell you what makes me
feel like you guys it's you that's what
it is what what makes
like when i'm already super horny the
idea that someone is like i like being
spread open with fingers
not by a penis i like how you make it
look like it's an iphone like they're
spreading it
like
this
so like let's say foreign
if someone's already like say fingering
you but like to just spread it open i
like the sensation of that i think about
that when i masturbate i um
um i think about being [ __ ] from
behind and then being my ass cheeks
completely being spread you would not
have liked having that skin tag
[Laughter]
um but see what what do you think about
like what finally what's the last thing
you think about that really gets you
there i'm that i don't first of all it's
always changing you know
i'm always verbal
things are always different all right
you can either do this or eat they loot
do we have bay loot for her we're like
i do what you do the opposite
i just white up your words i really do
like it's way cuter it sounds way cuter
what is it is um
duck egg
oh that
it's delicious but it has the feathers
it depends what stage it's in oh yeah
jewels
there it is
oh no
no so you can either answer what you
think about or you can eat one of those
we should start we gotta do a real truth
or dare on this [ __ ] you guys we have
next episode true uh true truth or dare
with some nasty [ __ ] okay oh my god or
maybe on the live
oh that is so repulsive to me that is
making me vegan again oh oh
i was gonna say something bad can i say
it
it's much worse i'm sorry
you know my friend just got um
she had um
cysts in her ovaries removed recently
and when they took out the cysts they
were teratomas they had the teeth the
hair everything i
don't like this conversation anymore
faith is where she draws the beaks and
teeth
feathers she was still on
feathers i was trying to understand what
was going on still but you know how like
cats say for instance they have tiny
little like protrusions in their penises
like they have little hooks in their
penises so when they mate with a female
cat it kind of sinks it sinks into the
[ __ ] it kind of lashes out yeah
basically oh
look it's like they're tongues like dick
teeth
oh baby dick teeth yeah we have spikes
you guys i have to talk about this i
haven't been able to talk about this yet
this is what your final thought when you
break before you come that's what i
think about that
randy's penis is so small that
don't
carlos is turned on at that
no i knew a dog with a small dick and
everyone made fun of the dog and i
always felt bad for the dog
it's like
he pisses all over his stomach because
the there's nowhere for her to go it's
so cute i'll send you a picture of his
penis i want to see it's actually so
cute you probably want to suck it a
little bit it's like a little nipple
well i remember when i was looking to
adopt a dog and i found this dog that
was like so cute i was just in love with
it and then when i went to go meet it at
the shelter it was so
ugly bad
like it would
only attack and it's i'll never forget
its dick was so big and i'm like oh i
always love a big dog i have uh my dog
stubs is the sweetest dog ever oh i love
stubs
yeah he drags his dick all around town
so there's no correlation between them
his dick is so [ __ ] big i would say
it's bigger than bobby's or most men
that i know actually he has such a big
dick
well you just got back at bobby for
calling your [ __ ] standard thank you
maybe he meant like the standard hotel
like it was it was very classic it's out
of business now but you know it wasn't
even the downside
was in it every once in a while
everyone's standing in the bar i was
just sitting there for a while
i was so jealous of the box girls wait
what's the box girl oh my god at the
standard hotel on sunset boulevard they
literally behind the check-in counter
was a clear box that a hot girl would
just sit in
and like on display and they would just
be on their laptop like swinging their
feet it was actually so cool and i
applied and was no i don't even think i
was considered they would have all gone
to jail
can you imagine
where's the kalila tattoo did it go away
yet no no it's never going away isn't it
dave keeps bringing that up like it's
just not fading i feel like it's only
getting darker it does look darker let
me see it
ah this is so fun i hope it stays i
don't care i love it i think it's so
funny i
i will be sad when it goes away
that's so funny oh
you guys see kim kardashian wearing
marilyn monroe
and it was right after i saw the marilyn
monroe documentary the the on netflix i
watched it as well the missing tapes or
whatever yeah oh really was it good it
was really sad yeah like everything from
her relationship with arthur miller like
it just made me [ __ ] sad
yeah i felt really similarly it was a
real reminder that her life
was so tragic and even though i know i i
do think kim is an icon and i don't have
a problem with her wearing the dress i
thought it was such a cool cultural
moment it literally brought tears to my
eyes it was so amazing and fun to like
i love that it like reignited our
interest in marilyn a little but
i will say it made me realize
kim's life is not tragic and maryland's
was so tragic really true i'm not
offended by it but i'm like do your hair
like her
it's like annoying i'm like it doesn't
look enough like marilyn monroe to me
for it to like be
a win-win you know but it was cool i
like you know what my favorite part
about was that there were rumors that
they just hung out at ripley's believe
it or not before because that's where
they got the dress from yeah like the
idea that they were like oh pete and
and kim are just on a date at ripley's
believe it or not
that is just like they're just going to
wax museums and i guess maybe if you're
a watcher if you're early in a
relationship you go through every johnny
depp which by the way i'm so into the
fake johnny dubs now now that johnny
real johnny depp is just crushing it by
the way you look like i'm a little
i never realized that
i'll take that as a compliment daughter
is beautiful johnny yep imagine if you
were the next captain jack sparrow
what a win for us
i don't know what to say to you maybe
could be because he's kind of like
fumbles around
and i look really good with eyeliner
baby hi like that yeah
um
i have to say something really
that i am scared to admit but when i
listen to some of the johnny depp trial
i
a little bit
related to amber heard and i want you to
hear me out
you want us to amber hear you it's very
like
first of all
my take on these kinds of relationships
is that like it's usually it takes two
to tango like i don't think there's ever
typically one i mean sure there i can i
shouldn't speak generally but like it
seems to me in this situation like it
takes you to tango and like they were in
a toxic thing that they had together but
the thing first of all i'm not that kind
of person like the yelling and whatever
she was doing that was about no not at
all i've seen her yell at you a little
bit and you were like can you believe
what happened
she wagged her finger and my face was
like wow she's never been hit
[Applause]
was when they would get into fights
he would leave the room and she would go
crazy and that is such a trigger for me
like feeling abandoned i just lose
my ability to now imagine your dad
wanted you aborted how would you feel
[ __ ]
how would you i'd be like well i made it
here i'm fine
no
you're so full of [ __ ] i swear i stand
by that because i was also conceived on
like a whim
i was not conceived out of like people
trying and wanting it was more like my
mom wanted to move into his house and oh
my god you are your mother's daughter
yes thank you um
but do you guys know what i'm saying
like when you with the amber hurt stuff
um i've done this in previous
relationships where i feel like i wasn't
like it was just toxic altogether where
if the person would leave the room
i couldn't deal with that person leaving
the room so i would leave the house
like i had to one-up the leaving and one
of the abandonment because i was so hurt
in that moment of them not wanting to
solve something with me i don't do that
anymore obviously yeah but when i was in
my young 20s and just very like confused
about like how to like cope with
difficulties in relationships i would do
that i'd be like as soon as they'd be
like i can't talk right now i'd be like
well that's it start i would start
packing my stuff yeah and then i would
just leave the house and then ghost them
i packed because i was just too hurt by
that one move so i'm gonna one-up their
move and that's so [ __ ] up of me to
have done that but i that feeling is
what i had yeah and i can hear it in her
voice and the things that she's saying
in those tapes that are so hard to
listen to um
but she's so clearly she's so desperate
for him to just like say i'm here with
you and i love you
and
it's i don't know it's so he's also
taking care of himself in that moment
absolutely and i'm not
because the way she's acting is so
bad that i understand why when you're in
a situation like that you have to just
leave that's what you have to do because
otherwise they're just going to keep
yelling at you you're shutting your bed
yeah did you hear any of it what are
your thoughts
i honestly i'm just reignited and really
loving johnny depp he's just making me
laugh so much and it's annoying if
someone's like smirking in your face and
stuff if you're in a fight like i'm sure
he was doing that and i could see that
making driving her crazy and stuff
i don't know i'm trying to like it's
hard because i am really trying to stay
out of people's business because i feel
like every time i get in people's
business it ends up being like
so stressful for me or whatever so i've
been like trying to not get people's
business and then
so this is the most being in someone's
business you can but it is like and i'm
friends with stan hope and stuff who's
really close with johnny depp and stuff
so i feel like i
i'm already on the team johnny just by
association not that i have to be or
anything but
the clips i really like are when they
catch her like faking her being an
actress really oh yeah they'll catch her
like
she'll be like
oh [ __ ]
it's like she's a psycho dude really
yeah she's [ __ ] crazy yeah allegedly
allegedly
you got to be careful on this show
you know what i just um
i am team neither
yeah i don't know
where they're doing it it's like you
guys are obsessed with each other still
too by the way can you imagine yes i
actually believe that they're still into
each other it's like why would you still
be so attached to that
because i dropped my houses
well no because i think there's still so
much unresolved between them that i
think that they couldn't have they
couldn't be more bonded to each other in
this moment i think it's going to be
years before they're able to shut each
other off each other's systems and i i'm
team neither just because i don't know
um i i'm sure she
she seems like she's been unhinged
several times but he's also somebody who
was a very messy addict so it's like
both of you [ __ ] were messy as
[ __ ] toxic as [ __ ] you're both adults
you couldn't figure it out i'm team
[ __ ] neither i'm like
you both deserve this this is nasty but
it's just like because i've been in bad
relationships like i've had two
particularly horrible relationships and
one was with this guy back in the day
when i first started comedy this fat fat
fat [ __ ] and oh god he was fat and he
was like really mean to my mom and
there's like all these it was just such
a fat and i used to really want to like
one up i would start to like stop hating
him just like out of time and
whatever
and then i would be like i almost wanna
like hang out with him to remember how
much because he would always without
fail just do something horrific in front
of me like yell at his new girlfriend or
something just be like such a psycho
and i would see him at like parties and
stuff and i just like you're here and i
never like gave up that
because i just like it was just when you
see someone make your mother cry two
times it's like
how do you like it
but
i don't give a sh i never think about
that guy i don't i'm kind of embarrassed
about the whole situation i would not
even say anything to him now like but i
did i was like i i liked hating him it
was funny well there are some people
i guess this i will i wouldn't have
cared if he told people things about me
because it would people wouldn't have
believed him do you know what i mean i
think for johnny depp she said all the
stuff about him and then he didn't get
to say the stuff about her right so i
think that's where there are some type
of
like [ __ ] abusive types of people who
just won't let it go it's like um
in her case she did that op-ed right
where it's like it was already over
it was sort of like probably not the
most amicable split but it was still
over and then she just
couldn't let it go she had to write that
thing and kind of like you know
she had to win right that's what it
seemed like she had to feel that feeling
of winning writing that op-ed saying all
those things about him but needing to
have that win is like you're still so
attached like right how my other like
toxic relationship that where i was not
good in that relationship either like i
really like got into the spin of it
and it's just it's very nice to be with
someone that does not activate i'm never
really like upset and it's very nice but
when you have those people where it's
like they just elevate and they love it
and you're watching their face like
excitedly getting you [ __ ] worked up
that guy i don't i've worked on myself i
have no interest in being new i don't
but that's the only way to do it is just
like clean cut but even if you talk [ __ ]
on me i'd be like i don't know there's
just like certain people where you're
just like yeah i don't even care if you
say anything about me but she did it so
publicly i only really have one
ex-boyfriend who i loathe with my every
like on a molecular level
yeah and he was just i took me a year
and a half to figure out he was a
full-blown narcissist was a punch of the
window guy no no i don't even hate him i
am i offer him empathy and understanding
because i'm like i think that he deals
with mental
illness and stuff and i'm like all right
that's fine no but it was someone who
was much older than me the the first guy
that i dated um when i was 22 he was 38
and um he was physically abusive he was
emotionally abusive i still think that
he is i don't know if i'm allowed to say
this but i think he was dealing with his
sexual identity
um
and we all know that closeted gay man
can be very very abusive are you here to
hit us don't hit us carlos why are you
coming up to us right now
carlos
scary
but it was the first time where um he
was one of those types of guys that if i
didn't
completely extract myself move far away
he would have just kept going and trying
to like re-enter my life and trying to
get a rise out of me in some way so like
i there are people like that and i do
think that there is something about
amber heard that made her feel like this
is not resolved i want to keep
you know
fighting yeah but also don't you feel
like what those narcissists do like did
you ever like with my because i think i
mean i this was a troubled guy so like i
also have empathy i mean it's like love
for all of them but like
i just don't like
it doesn't work anymore yeah but i was
like
thinking like there was one time
when we after we broke up i needed to go
back to the house
because i got locked out of where i was
staying and so i needed to go back to
the house and i went back to our place
and he was there
and i wasn't like i had completely shut
him out i wasn't talking or anything and
so i figured out how to get my keys back
and then there was like a second and i
was like i went
i went oh um
how are you i just gave like one moment
and he went
oh
and he did this like fake sad thing and
i went no and then i left i was like
absolutely not like i just saw him
switch the which is what i saw in amber
heard whoa where she just switches the
thing and i'm like i don't know if
that's like a narcissistic thing or
whatever i don't know but my narcissist
ex-boyfriend um i
this is when i didn't have a lot of
money and i had these really um favorite
cowboy boots that i owned and when i
asked you well he had told me hey you
left your cowboy boots here and i was
like oh this is a decision do i just
leave them yeah um or do i just do i
pick them up i was like [ __ ] it like i
don't have the money to buy a new pair
they're my favorite so i go over there i
do the
the the far drive
to pick up my cowboy boots and then when
i get there he's like oh i only found
one
and then i was like ah [ __ ] it i'll take
the one because what he was doing was
two weeks after he was like oh i found
the other one of course right
and i never picked up the second one so
i have one cowboy boot if um good for
you yeah so i just have a left foot i
always say
never get the thing back there's nothing
yeah like but you had you had to go to
get that lesson like once you got there
you realized like oh [ __ ] yeah
because i'm just like there's nothing
that's like worth my piece right it's
too terrified to retrieve the second
boot so guys the second boot's not worth
it just
sever the ties if you guys can find that
boot for her you'll get free merch
well thank you old sperm [ __ ]
yes i want it next time i want to have
todd tell you guys what it was like for
him to jerk off in a cup i'm really
excited really funny the story is
electric you guys please subscribe to
this channel please comment on this
video help us share this with friends
like let's grow
let's grow grow grow why did i say that
i'm tired she's little she wants to grow
you should get that surgery where they
get you make you a couple more inches is
that real because when i was little my
dad told me about that i thought it was
just teasing me no they haven't now
what yeah you can um i think the the
latest one on the news was some guy who
was like oh i'm five seven but tomorrow
i'll be five ten you know
if it's only three inches just do the
deck do you know what i mean like who
cares what do you mean do the dick just
stretch your dick out make your dick
longer it's like the three inches
doesn't matter annie i have to tell you
something i don't have a dick oh i'm not
talking about i'm saying in general the
people i i will say this i cannot i have
seen you naked
i cannot decide what i prefer in bed if
i prefer a short king or a tall king or
a medium medium kim i like them all like
when i've had like my before bobby my ex
was the last guy that i dated he was
like 6'4 this big buff you know um um
footy player
and then but when i got with bobby it
was so brand new the stark difference of
it i loved i had so much fun with him in
bed they climb you like a tree it's
amazing i love short guys i i one of the
like the best like lovers i hate saying
that but one of the best bangs i had was
this guy who was short and skinny and he
would just climb me esther i don't think
that dream can never be realized for you
it's hard to find a guy
i think smaller than you aside from brad
williams i know what i'm saying but it
would be a woman
we're not even pretending
all right
see you guys next week
you